hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten welt ich werde heute eine
donauwelle packen also mal wieder ein
classic und die donau will haben sich
ganz viele von euch gewünscht ich hab
versprochen wenn ich wieder einen
klassik macht dann mache ich die
donauwelle haben sich auch einige die
schwarzwälder kirschtorte gewünscht die
werde ich dann nächstes mal machen das
kommt auch jetzt schon ganz bald und ich
habe jetzt auch gerecht ganz viele
videos die ich noch machen muss
ich werde morgen mein papa video drehen
das kommt dann noch nächste woche
natürlich vor dem ramadan fest
dann kommt noch mein küchen video das
konnte ich nicht machen weil ein paar
innen ausstattungsteile noch fehlen und
das verzögert sich einfach gerade alles
und ja es waren so die wichtigsten
videos und dann kommen natürlich auch
ganz viele andere noch schafft so eine
ewig lange liste und ich würde sagen ich
starte jetzt einfach mal mit der
donauwelle ich mache sie ganz klassisch
mit buttercreme und zeigt euch das
einfach mal die zutaten für den rührteig
ihr braucht für den teig 250 gramm
butter die ist immer warm 200 gramm
zucker fünf eier essen auch zimmer war
375 gramm mehl eine packung backpulver
eine prise salz ein bisschen
vanilleschote oder eine packung
vanillezucker 20 gramm kakaopulver etwa
1 bis 2 esslöffel milch
deshalb schauen wir dann einfach nach
bedarf und ein glas sauerkirschen die
habe ich jetzt vorher schon geöffnet und
abgegossen und habt ihr jetzt so ohne
den saft hier in den teller gegeben
den saft brauchen wir nämlich bei diesem
kuchen nicht das sind wir ganz normale
zutaten für den ganz normalen rührteig
und ich habe jetzt bereits weile
backform vorbereitet und zwar habe ich
hier meinen back rahmen auf einem
backblech mit der back folie könnte aber
auch einfach ein backblech nehmen und
ganz normales und dieses mit etwas
backpapier auskleiden oder einfach gut
einfetten also ein tiefes backblech geht
auch ihr braucht keinen back rahmen
dafür
und ich wette das ganze jetzt in der
küchenmaschine mache aber ihr könnt auch
einfach ein handfunkgerät nehmen zuerst
gibt ihr jetzt die weiche butter in die
rührschüssel
dann kommt der zucker mit dazu und das
ganze wird richtig schön weiß cremig
verrührt anschließend gibt jetzt
nacheinander die fünf eier mit dazu und
lass alles gut zu einer homogenen masse
verrühren
ich berühre jetzt schon das mehl mit dem
backpulver dem vanillezucker und dem
salz und gebt das dann anschließend dazu
und dann kommt eventuell noch eins bis
zwei esslöffel milch mit dazu
das soll einfach ein fester teig seien
nicht zu flüssig aber auch natürlich
nicht ganz trocken
so sieht dann der fertige teig aus und
hiervon gebe ich jetzt etwa zwei drittel
bereits in meinen backblech den rest
stelle ich hier wieder zurück und geht
jetzt hier etwas kakaopulver rein und
nochmal etwa zwei esslöffel milch
denn durch das kakaopulver wird es eher
ziemlich fest und das soll er die
gleiche konsistenz haben wieder heran
jetzt verteidigt es hier schön also eher
unschön weil wir und unregelmäßig jetzt
verteidigt den teig hier unregelmäßig
und ihr seht auch ich habe den rahmen
nicht sehr groß eingestellt und schieben
jetzt auch noch mal ganz kurz zusammen
und zwar würde ich da maximal eine größe
von ja so etwa 30 mal 25 nehmen ich
möchte mich eher dass der/die donauwelle
etwas höher wird und jetzt gebe ich den
dunklen tag drauf man könnte auch den
hellen tag als eine schicht drauf geben
und stand den dunklen als eine schicht
und somit einer gabel marmorieren aber
ich mach das auch ganz gerne in flecken
jetzt wird es einfach schön verteilt
das nehme ich mir einfach eine gabel und
marmoriert das jetzt nur ein bisschen
das sieht es ein bisschen vermischt und
da gebe ich jetzt einfach noch die
sauerkirschen rein
die gibt übrigens in jedem supermarkt zu
kaufen bei den konservierten sachen
und so darf der teig für etwa 25 bis 30
minuten bei 190 grad ober und unterhitze
in den vorgeheizten backofen
ihr müsst natürlich auch zum schluss die
stäbchen probe machen und dann zeige ich
euch den fertigen teig
während meinen tag jetzt noch back werde
ich schon mal die buttercreme
vorbereiten und zwar besteht die aus
pudding und butter und damit der pudding
schön abkühlen kann weil ich den jetzt
vorbereiten und dafür braucht er auch
noch vier zutaten und zwar habe ich hier
500 milliliter milch 60 gramm zucker und
40 gramm speisestärke und etwas
vanilleschote wobei er die wanne schon
finde ich unbedingt braucht und zum
beispiel auch einfach etwas vanille
zucker nehmen könnt ich werde jetzt das
ganze hier auch im topf machen und zwar
gebt ihr jetzt die milch in den topf da
gebe ich aber nicht alles rein sondern
lasso etwa 7 esslöffel drin damit ich
die mit der stärke verführen kann und
die milch im topf werde ich jetzt schon
mal kochen lassen
vanille hab ich jetzt hier mit rein
visuell die panthers ich war dass ihm
videos schneiden und das summen des
kombis von dem topf von der
induktionsplatte hier gebe ich noch
zucker mit rein und jetzt kochte milch
und jetzt gebe ich da die stärke
mischung dazu und jetzt merkt man auch
schon dass sie ein gedeckt ist und ich
lasse jetzt nur noch einmal aufkochen
und jetzt füllt ich mir das einfach
wieder hier zurück in die kleine
schüssel und damit sich darauf jetzt
keine haut bildet brauchen wir etwas
frischhaltefolie und legen sie direkt
auf den pudding
ich hab jetzt keine da und habe jetzt
einfach eine gefriertruhe zerschnitten
und schlägt die da jetzt drauf direkt
auf den pudding damit einfach keine kein
sauerstoff dran kommt und sich da nicht
diese haut bildet und so lasse ich den
pudding jetzt abkühlen und habe auch
bereits eine portion butter
herausgestellt damit die zimmer warm
wird und dann sehen wir uns gleich
wieder wenn der teig fertig ist und
nicht die creme machen kann
also ich habe jetzt hier die warme
butter dessen 250 gramm
und hier haben
den pudding des auch abgekühlt also
beides hatte zimmertemperatur und
stärkten hat wie ihr sehen könnt keine
haut also das hat sich jetzt nicht
gebildet eben dadurch dass wir jetzt die
pole darüber hatten den pudding werde
ich jetzt hier aber trotzdem um eben zu
vermeiden dass klümpchen drin sind durch
ein sieb streichen und in der zeit kann
dann schon mal die butter richtig schön
cremig gerührt werden
und jetzt wird immer ein esslöffel
pudding in die butter rein gerührt bis
das ganze aufgebraucht ist und dann ist
unsere buttercreme auf fertig
und jetzt gebe ich diese fertige
buttercreme einfach auf den abgekühlten
teils auch im kühlschrank also der
kuchen ist jetzt richtig schön kalt
und so muss die torte jetzt nochmal
gekühlt werden und anschließend werde
ich dann die kuvertüre drauf geben
meinen kuchen besitzerin kühlschrank und
ich werde schon mal die schokolade
vorbereiten
und zwar habe ich hier 250 gramm peter
kuvertüre und habe davon etwa 50 bis 60
gramm weg gelegt oder ein bisschen mehr
das war so ungefähr ein drittel
und hier habe ich noch ein bisschen
palme das ist so sind vielleicht zehn
oder 15 gramm und zwar brauchen wir das
familien damit die schokolade später
nicht so hart wird wenn ich auf die
kante buttercreme streichen
und dann bricht die schokolade nicht
wenn mir die torte anschneiden
jetzt war noch etwas kochendes wasser
und gibt es hier jetzt einfach rein und
ich werde jetzt die schokolade im heißen
wasserbad schmelzen
also einfach da rein legen und sobald
die schokolade hier komplett aufgelöst
gebe ich dann noch das drittel mit dazu
ich könnte das ist natürlich auch im
thermomix machen oder in der kenwood das
hat er beides küchenmaschinen mit
temperatur also mit hitze funktion und
im in der erkenntnis es sogar so dass
sie bis auf zwei grad genau erhitzen
kann
das heißt die ist super zum temperiert
von carolath aber auch im thermomix wird
es geht bei ungefähr 36 grad
und so war die schokolade jetzt komplett
aufgelöst ist nämlich sehr oft im
wasserbad heraus und geht jetzt die
restliche schokolade dazu damit die
schokolade hier wieder auf temperatur
kommen also damit sie abkühlen denn wenn
man sie so benutzen ist zu heiß und dann
wird die schokolade eben er bekommt sie
keinen schönen glanz sondern wird eher
matt und eben nicht so schön und ich
zeige dass jetzt heute im wasserbad weil
ich mir gedacht habe es haben bestimmt
nicht alle irgendwie einen thermomix
oder kenwood und ich wollte euch einfach
zeigen wie man das auch ohne
küchenmaschine machen kann und ihr könnt
es natürlich auch in der mikrowelle
machen aber das empfehle ich eher nicht
so weil da die gefahr besteht dass die
schokolade verbrennt und ihr seht auch
die schokolade glänzt auch richtig schön
und jetzt sollte es ja auch gleich die
richtige tempo
so haben und ich gebe es hier gleich
noch das palm ihn mit rein damit sich
das auch auflösen kann
hier ist meine schokolade geschmolzen
und gebt sie gleich auf meinen kuchen
der kann jetzt direkt aus dem
kühlschrank
aber wir haben ja gerade auf 37 grad und
bei uns ist sehr warm in der küche
deswegen muss ich schnell arbeiten und
eigentlich macht mal buttercreme bei so
heißen tagen nicht so gern weil ja es
ist einfach zu warm und dann ganz
schnell verteilen
bevor ich es jetzt ganz glatt streichen
gebe ich das nur für eine minute etwa in
den kühlschrank war ansonsten gleich die
schokolade davonläuft und jetzt nehme
ich einfach so eine tankkarte die sieht
aus wie sohn kam und sie hier kleine
wellen in die schokolade
wenn ihr aber keine zeitkarte habt könnt
auch einfach eine gabel nehmen so mache
ich jetzt hier auch am rand mein kuchen
ist es gekühlt und bevor ich ihn nicht
schneiden kann muss ich natürlich erst
die folie entfernen
das könnt ihr übrigens ganz einfach so
machen und dann einfach drunter
wegdrehen
jetzt werde ich noch mal den rand ihr
entfernen und jetzt könnt ihr gerne
diesem kuchen ein teilnehmen zum
abdrücken und eben schneiden dann habt
ihr mich immer gleich große stücke
der hat hier auf der einen seite 30 und
auf der anderen 20 20 24 stücke und wenn
ihr den habt könnt ihr übrigens mit dem
auch vorher bei vor dem backen die form
einstellung habe ich fragen ganz
vergessen denn jetzt passt es nicht ganz
genau drauf das ist immer gleich sind
als ihr hättet es freuen einstellen
können so wie ich bei der milch schnitte
gemacht hatte
aber ich möchte sowieso nicht den ganzen
kuchen aufschneiden und macht jetzt
einfach nach augenmaß und dann setzt
sich die dauerwelle einfach auf eine
tortenplatte und ich stelle meine jetzt
aber gleich noch mal kühl jeweils
nämlich nicht lange genug im kühlschrank
deswegen ist die butter auch noch nicht
fest und ich kann die forderung nicht so
gut schneiden aber bei mir geht gleich
das licht weg deswegen mache ich das
jetzt einfach filmen und so sieht dann
die fertige donauwelle aus ihr könnt ihr
übrigens natürlich auch in nach hunden
backform backen
da können dann zum beispiel das gesamte
rezept in der 32er springform backen
oder errechnet euch runter ich habe euch
ja mal auf meinem blog eine umrechnung
tabelle reingestellt und da könnt ihr
das dann einfach umrechnen
ich wünsche dir auf jeden fall ganz viel
spaß mit dem rezept mit dieser
klassischen donauwelle es gibt ja schon
viele abwandlungen mit quark und sahne
das eben die buttercreme nicht so schwer
ist aber ich muss sagen daher der teig
mehr ist und wenig buttercreme ist
findet ihr die novelle so immer sehr
sehr lecker
auf jeden fall wünsche euch jetzt einen
guten appetit ganz viel spaß und ich hab
auch bevor samira die kaffee schokolade
weg ist bis zum nächsten mal wieder bis
bald nein das war liegt machen jetzt mit
dem putting weiter okay